sweetheart marker and the pie would be
about a stuffed stomach that is frost it
would be directly below his eye line
yeah right his crotch oh I see it got
you yes well just hold it over his unit
here we go there I can explain is that
the right diet for take two mark
it's one time at band camp I was
supposed to go to this party
well it wasn't really a party then and
Isaiah Lewin their cheerleader baby she
wants me she asked me for my number I
asked myself the question what's the
difference if it's 100 girls or one as
long as the stifmeister can come through
and give all a little bit of peace the
pie yeah baby
look at these dimples are very hard yeah
this one time at band camp there was
this guy there he's from Jersey they
smelled so bad it's like you hey you
done
oh thank you thank you so much murder
yes sir this one time at band camp
there's this horse who had the biggest
saddle marker melv
yeah no take your head out to your left
little bit yeah like that
yeah oh it's not what it looks like